if you're 60 i hate to say to you you're
not 60.
you were 60 60 years ago if you were 60
then today if you're 60 you're 40 years
old because you're living to 85 years
old stop thinking you're 60 years old
you're 45 years old you are naive if
you're what i'll do respect to boobers i
got respect for you because you came
before i did with all due respect if you
are naive if you're a boomer at 60
thinking about retiring in five years
you ought to change your retirement plan
to 12 years at 72 not because oh my gosh
that's so unfair the government is so
unfair no because you're gonna live
longer and if you decide to retire at 65
you'll be broke at 79 years old
miserable
being a little bit of a challenge to
your kids you may even come in between
your kids marriage whoever they're
married to because they're going to be
sitting there behind closed doors in bed
saying how much more money do we have to
take care of your mom how much more
money do we have to pay for your dad you
may cause a divorce amongst your kids
and whoever they're married to so game
plan you're 60 you're going to 72 have
the conversation with your wife have the
conversation with your husband go get a
side gig whatever that side gig maybe do
real estate go to retirement go to
insurance guess what
sell whatever people at your age are
interested in because that's your market
go sell mets up go some med advantage go
sell you know a long term care go sell
whatever experience you are going
through go sell a 401k and say listen
this was my 401k a 700 700 000 it's at
420. if you're like me this is what i'm
doing do you want to hear about it
figure out a way to generate income for
yourself i talked to a lot of them in
there in that age 60 plus and a lot of
them are flat out saying i'm not
retiring at 65. and they have a million
in the bank
in their retirement and they have two
million in retirement a million two
million of retirement today at 60 years
old is nothing crazy because you got a
plan for at least 25 years you have to
plan to 85 don't solve for i'm gonna die
at 72 years old no you're gonna solve
for 85 years old and by the way
everybody else
30 year old 40 year old 50 year old
that's going through a mess maybe by the
way the divorce business is going to
blow up next two years yeah i can
imagine it's sad but it's sad but it's
going to blow up the next two years
therapy is going to blow up the next two
years
i hate to say it and i hope this
industry doesn't blow up they're going
to because the first thing doctors are
going to prescribe is what
antidepressants are going to blow up the
next two years oh yeah you're gonna see
a lot of weird stories the next two
years we talked about this the other
night that we're here if you're
listening to this and you're scared only
be scared if you're not planning to
increase your value in the marketplace
you have nothing to be scared of if you
are going to be improving and learning
two three four five new skill sets to
improve yourself in the marketplace
because the market is going to pay you
if you improve
the people that are scared today are the
people that are watching way too many
tick tock videos yeah way too many
instagram videos way too many netflix
shows way too many video games let me
tell you if you're watching this get off
this podcast because this podcast is
going to be very scary for you the next
three six 12 months because i'm not
gonna stop talking about this get off
your damn video games and the netflix
take a six-month sabbatical from netflix
and freaking video games and tic toc
take a break
and go learn a skill set go on udemy go
on pluralsight go on any of these
whatever courses you can take there go
take some master class go take a
work under somebody to learn something
go watch some youtube videos from people
that are teaching you there's great real
estate youtube videos there's great
insurance youtube videos there's one
called seven figure squad there's so
many of them that you can go learn from
these people out there but if you don't
do that
don't blame the government
don't blame the rich people don't blame
your parents don't blame your family
don't blame anybody if you refuse to
improve you the next two years and by
the way i hate to say to you this
happened to my family and nine and when
i got out of the military in 1990 i got
out of the military
my dad had another heart attack he went
to the hospital we were watching the
game where allen iverson made that shot
over uh
tyrone lou wow game ended he says take
me to the hospital i'm having a heart
attack i took him to the hospital he's
having a heart attack i'm saying like oh
great 49k in debt buddy you're killing
it pvd what are you gonna do the only
thing you know how to do is shoot a
freaking rifle and you're not even an
expert at it you were advanced
so what am i gonna go say uh listen uh
ibm you guys need somebody with a good
you know
i want to say i'm gonna be a humber
mechanic i'm going to be the best humber
mechanic in california there was 200
dealerships
one was in camarillo here's what the guy
said in the interview no joke he told me
says sir i said i'm the best hummer
mechanic in all of fort campbell
kentucky look at my i'm sick yeah i'm
your best he says sir we sell two
hummers a month
we have one mechanic and it's one too
many that's a perfect we don't need you
i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] what a waste of a
skill set i can shoot then i can fix
hummers and i'm broke you still got hope
they're bringing it back there's still
hope but the point is i i sat there and
i said i'm going to increase my market
value i think that's what everybody can
do that's amazing if you don't do it you
should be scared if you do do it don't
worry about it future looks bright so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]